Genau 200 jahre nach der veröffentlichung des bekannten frankenstein romans haben forschungsteams weltweit nicht nur mischwesen wie
menschen schimären
Im labor geschaffen es gibt auch konkrete pläne das erste mal gezielt in die evolution einzugreifen
weitere beispiele für solche projekte aller frankenstein und wo demnächst eine genetische
Atombombe gezündet wird jetzt in klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Wir haben hier ja schon öfter darüber berichtet schon länger machen
Gentechnik teams auch nicht mehr vor experimenten mit menschen halt und es ist zum einen wirklich sensationell was heute
Biomedizinische möglich ist auf der anderen seite ist die forschung auf diesem gebiet auch wirklich furchteinflößend und macht mir
Öfter mal gänsehaut aber nicht, so im positiven wie bei diesem beispiel in china haben wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
genmanipulierte embryonen geschaffen und die hätten sie tatsächlich
Zu menschen heranwachsen lassen können noch ist das nicht passiert die embryonen wurden nicht
ausgetragen aber das ist wahrscheinlich nur noch eine frage der zeit
konkret haben sie intakte gen abschnitte in die erbkranken menschlichen embryonen eingesetzt
In drei von sechs fällen verlief die korrektur der gene tatsächlich erfolgreich das alles führt uns in eine zeit in der es
im bereich der reproduktionsmedizin
Das normal sein wird menschen zu designen in eine etwas andere richtung geht die forschung im bereich
neurobiologie wissenschaftlerinnen wissenschaftler erschaffen, so genannte gehirn organo ide
menschliche stammzellen werden zu hirnzellen
Ausdifferenziert diese wachsen dann tatsächlich zu einem mini gehirn heran man kann es kaum glauben aber die zellen
knüpfen verbindung und bilden sechs zellschichten auf typisch für die großhirnrinde
könnten solche fast gehirne da nicht auch anfangen zu fühlen oder zu denken die beteiligten
Forschungsteams tun diese zweifel ab schließlich bekämen die minne gehirne jack einen sinnes input und zudem sei ihre größe viel zu gering
Bislang sind die mini gehirne nicht durchblutet sobald sie so groß sind wie eine linse
Reicht die versorgung mit sauerstoff und nährstoffen nicht mehr aus doch
Genau das will jetzt ein neurochirurg von der universität von pennsylvania ändern
Und man seine experimente sind wirklich unfassbar cars sein forschungsteam baut solche
menschlichen fast mini gehirne in die sehrinde von ratten ein und das mit erfolg
Die kleinen kunst gehirne sind so also mit blut und
Sinneseindrücken versorgt und ja man kann es wirklich so formulieren diese menschen
eine schimäre machen es möglich dass menschliches gewebe durch ratten augen schaut und so die welt wahrnimmt
Ich habe echt ein ungutes gefühl dabei wie groß ist hier die gefahr dass sich diese
Im labor erschaffenen kreaturen anna gegen uns wenden frankenstein des größten derzeit überschlagen sich tatsächlich die nachrichten aus diesem bereich die
biomedizin und die genetik übernehmen quasi ingenieurs aufgaben und manipulieren das leben so wie es gefällt der schlüssel dazu ist
Sie so genannte chris pratt technik über die wir hier schon öfter berichtet haben diese gegen schere macht die
manipulation von erbgut sehr präzise und ist zudem noch sehr preiswert
Außerdem ist die methode selbst für anfänger sehr einfach anzuwenden demnächst werden vielleicht auch organspender überflüssig denn der plan ist es
menschliche organe wie nieren
Beispielsweise, im schweinen heranzuzüchten andere forschungsteams haben das ziel ausgestorbene tierarten wie beispielsweise das mammut wieder auferstehen zu lassen
Das hat man ja schon hier bei kik sowie anderes sehr erfolgreiches forschungsgebiet ist die synthetische biologie mit deren hilfe
bakterien design werden ein paar projekte die sich bereits in der umsetzung befinden bakterien die
protokollieren wie die krankheit ihrer wirte verläuft oder aber bakterien die
Dreifarbig sehen können zum schluss komme ich jetzt noch, zu einem projekt das so wirklich
Einmalig auf der erde wäre in burkina faso wird ein forschungsteam demnächst wohl das erste mal gezielt
In die evolution eingreifen der konkrete plan sieht so aus dass
Im bauerndorf bana mücken ausgesetzt werden die in ihrem erbgut ein unfruchtbarkeit gehen haben laut den bisher
durchgeführten
computersimulationen wird sich dieses gehen dann in der gesamten mücken population ausbreiten
Die idee des forschungsteams das übrigens
Im auftrag der bill & melinda gates stiftung arbeitet malaria einzudämmen denn der malaria-erreger
Nutzt diese mücken als wird und diese wird es dann wohl nur noch in
verminderter anzahl geben wenn der plan aufgeht und der mensch die natur tatsächlich
austricksen kann dieses verfahren wird in der wissenschaftssprache übrigens als jean drive bezeichnet kritiker nennen es
Genetische atombombe denn die gene werden sich wohl so rasch verbreiten wie es auch bei einer nur klären kettenreaktionen der fall ist
natürlich biologisch also ganz schnell plötzlich sei nicht in sekundenbruchteilen all diese projekte
lassen sich doch irgendwie mit dem frankenstein roman in verbindung bringen bringen doch inwieweit haben wir daraus gelernt
Werden die heutigen experimente in den genen laboren dieser welt in einer katastrophe wird die menschheit enden
Feststehen falls man wird diese experimente nicht stoppen können doch es braucht instanzen die solche projekte um gentech geschöpfe
kontrollieren und daraufhin prüfen ob sie zum wohl der menschen sind wenn ihr zuallererst
Neues zum thema und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann meldet euch hierbei whatsapp an dann erfahrt ihr vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
garantiert ihr könnt direkt eben vorschläge machen oder andere ideen vorschlagen der direkte draht zu mir einfach
draufklicken gestern abend haben es schon
wahnsinn 2000 gemacht und ich habe wirklich jede nachricht beantwortet nein wie ein fass ziele hier geht es weiter mit dafür drauf klicken das mammut
wiederbeleben doktor frankenstein wird realität und natürlich abonnieren nicht vergessen ansonsten bis dann
gleich krank